Speaker 1: We are starting today with what
are effectively, in a sense, counter sanctions,
sanctions issued not only sanctions but also
bans from the country of Russia issued by
the Kremlin against the number of American
officials up to and including Joe Biden.
Now there's not very much that's funny about
what's going on with the Russian invasion
of Ukraine.
There's just very little that's funny in all
of this.
But the sanctions and banning Biden from Russia,
it's a little bit funny.
I will tell you, there's a Newsweek piece
about this Russia sanctions Joe and Hunter
Biden, which I just find hilarious.
Hillary Clinton and 10 others President Joe
Biden, his son, Hunter Biden, Hillary Clinton
and 10 other officials have been sanctioned
by Russia in response to the sweeping sanctions
imposed by Washington, the Russian government
announced today yesterday.
Rather, the sanctions barred the officials
from entering Russia.
Russia's Foreign Ministry said in a statement
translated to English that the measures were
on the basis of reciprocity now here.
It's actually beneficial that the people that
are sanctioned don't need to go to Russia
and don't have bank accounts in Russia and
don't have assets in Russia, and it makes
it all pretty weak.
Now you'll remember that Russian oligarchs,
organizations and entities have been targeted
by U.S., Europe and Canada in response to
the Ukrainian invasion by Russia.
Russian President Putin himself has been directly
sanctioned.
The translated Russian Foreign Ministry statement
Tuesday said the reciprocal sanctions were
the inevitable consequence of the extremely
Russo phobic Russia phobic course taken by
the administration.
Others sanctioned by Russia.
Secretary of State Antony Blinken.
Defense Secretary Lloyd Austin, chairman of
the Joint Chiefs Mark Milley.
CIA Director William Joseph Burns.
White House Press Secretary Jen Psaki, even
Jen Psaki.
And a bunch of other people now.
Jen Psaki was asked about this yesterday,
and she basically made the obvious points
about it.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: And one more of the sanctions were
imposed today by Russia against yourself,
President Biden and other top U.S. officials.
Do you have a response to that?
And how will it impact any of you, if at all?
Sure, I would first note that President Biden
is a junior, so they may have sanctioned his
dad.
May he rest in peace?
Speaker 1: Can you imagine?
I mean, this is one of those things where,
you know, in the United States what I love,
what Jen Psaki is saying, because it's almost
too on the nose.
And also irrelevant.
If you understand how Russia works, let me
explain what I mean by that.
On the one hand, in the U.S., if you sanction,
you know, Joseph Biden rather than Joseph
Biden Jr., you've not sanctioned the correct
person.
It doesn't matter what your intent was.
In some places, there's other places where
intent does matter, but it's sort of like
a legal question.
But we have the general belief in the U.S.
where like, that's a legit technicality, where
like if you don't say that it's junior, it
probably applies to someone other than the
person it's supposed to apply to.
And Jen Psaki is right about that.
But the other thing you have to understand
is in Russia, they don't care about technicalities
like that.
If the intention was to sanction Joe Biden,
the president of the United States, the fact
that Joe Biden is Biden's dad, deceased father,
they don't.
Those are not the types of technicalities
that courts in Russia care about unless it's
to their advantage, in which case all sorts
of technicalities you couldn't even imagine
will matter.
There's a bunch of interesting books that
talk about this, including Bill Browder's
book I believe it's called Red Notice.
He's been a guest on the show, even if you
don't like Bill Browder or you don't find
him trustworthy.
His explanation of how the the justice system
is a very amorphous thing in Russia are quite
quite interesting.
Let's get a little more here from Jen Psaki.
Speaker 2: It's the second piece, I would
say, is that won't surprise any of you, that
none of us are planning tourist trips to Russia.
None of us have bank accounts that we won't
be able to access, so we will forge ahead.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: At this point, I don't think anybody
is really looking to go to Russia from American
leadership.
It's interesting that Hillary's on the list,
but no Trump sanction, no Trump ban.
Also notable and interesting.
And of course, this is serious fuel for the
conspiracy theorists.
The conspiracy theorists are hearing this
and they are coming up with all sorts of different
hypotheses about why this is the list and
why is Hillary on the list?
That that's that's a really, really big deal.
To them, anything else of interest here?
Um.
Oh, this is notable at the same time, Russia
does not refuse to maintain official relations
if they meet our national interests, so they're
making it clear that even though these people
are banned and not allowed in Russia, if there
were some particular reason why they would
want to meet with people or maintain a diplomatic
relation, they will do that.
Of course, that that makes perfect sense.
Not a big surprise.
Imagine if they included Hunter Biden's laptop
on the list.
That would be pretty fascinating.
That would be
pretty fascinating.